le centre hospitalier de Versailles
poursuit sa phase de grands travaux
après les urgences est autour de la
maternité d'être repensé la première
pierre de l'extension vient d'être posée
elle comprendra des lit supplémentaires
une réalité chiffrée 1700 naissances
réalisé en 2007 2200 en 2012 là le
service va permettre d'assurer 2500
accouchements par an c'est un projet
porté depuis 10 ans il faut savoir qu'il
y a environ 8000 naissances dans le
bassin de population que actuellement
nous n'en faisons qu'un quart c'estàd
que les 3/4 des patientes sont vont en
clinique privée ou si elles veulent un
service public sont obligés de quitter
le département donc il y a une
insuffisance
notable ce bâtiment s'accompagnera de
deux nouveaux services la néo natalogie
et la
saintigraphie dans les ivelines sud nous
n'avons pas de service de néonat donc là
nous allons ouvrir 18 lits de
néonatologie et enfin la
satigraphie avec l'arrivée
d'un d'un matériel
révolutionnaire qui s'appelle le T scan
c'est un du matériel d'imagerie qui
permet en fait de voir des pathologies
qu'on peut qu'on ne peut pas voir
ailleurs et en
particulier pour tout ce qui est la
cancérologie l'ouverture de ce nouveau
bâtiment est prévu dans 2 ans pour un
coût de 27 millions d'euros le centre
hospitalier de Versailles a surparent
42000 d'hospitalisation et un tiers des
patients reçus sont
5tinis